[Music]
just eye widow
[Music]
[Music]
on the road couldn't be me i was right
i'm a path writing a check when i'm
writing a bar you want to find me when
i'm writing a party
6th of march on the 6th of march drink
up for the year like ah how many man
could have came this far
6th of march drink up on the 6th of
march drink up for the year like ah how
many yo
march is madness march is madness i got
dreams of selling out camden but right
now gotta shut down campus
i never been on badness but i'm a neat
cause i honor my profit
you said that you trapped but you're
still trying to pay off your pride you
don't make no profit
off topic kyle's with abby hey in
hackney
chilling at z's kitchen look at my fleas
different look at my feet
different look at my drip you're
freezing you're stuck in the past your
soul two thousand and leave it
nice on keep it's got no crowd but they
want to reload and weave it
here go stream my latest ep gi tv is out
now jump off stage and i get bear love
more link ups i don't that girl sneaky
still want to do more shots and she
knows i had way too much
madness not just madness
[Music]
okay okay
[Music]
big up for ross boy
eileen shaw day hey yo yj why you always
gonna make the fire
hear what i'm saying you gotta listen to
me when you're on your jack jones i
ain't them cleared rappers that you
brothers used to
i remember when they used to grab phones
now i'm hands-on with my calling i'm
making big
moves thinking about my future it's a
big mood
but right now i just really need a
masseuse what broken mechanisms do you
use
i'm trying to read a psalm i don't need
to hit the juice
to drop the roof because the sky is the
limit see my sons being stars no one's
crowding our vision
yeah we're taking first place but it's
not for the ribbon trying to show them
there's the end of the road if we stay
driven
cause this that late night tribe music
souling out to the lyrics to feel the
live music
i don't know where i'm going but if i
stay here i'll probably never make it so
i'm skating from the lies music
and there's a beauty and not knowing my
fate if you don't know about that
struggle you could never relate
it's not hard to keep your faith when
you're rich and you're paid if you lost
it all today would you still be the same
a television when i'm switching my mode
trying to get to av when i'm giving you
flows
not as i taking shots i'm just stating
my goals i'm the greatest not the god
and i'll let that be known
[Music]
yeah big up standout tv
my latest vp glow in the dark is out now
so make sure you stream that support
[Music]
you